we are going to hear from some people in
the audience we now take calls via
discord davidpakman.com
discord
let's go first to an old friend
i hope i still remember how to pronounce
your name this is
alisa medua from dallas did i do okay
uh you did all right i appreciate the
attempt and it's great to talk to you
again sir yes uh thank you sir what's
going on
yeah so um i've noticed that on the
campaign trail for the midterms uh many
candidates including josh mandel who i
don't recommend you looking up
um they're promoting uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
and they're talking about how it's gonna
be like good for the future so i'd just
like to get your thoughts on that yeah i
don't have any uh emotional attachment
to or opposition to bitcoin or
cryptocurrency um this is you know
there's a lot of people who are feeling
the need to be extremely black and white
on crypto my view on crypto is as
follows it's been around over a decade
at this point in time and while it is
still very volatile i see no reason to
think that it's going to go away if
scalability is addressed and transaction
fees are addressed
um i believe it's going to be around and
i believe it will there will be more
adoption due to the level of risk
financially that crypto represents the
volatility
my personal decision without advising
anyone else is i years ago put a roughly
three to five percent of my assets in
cryptocurrency that's done very well for
me but i also recognize it could do
poorly and that's why i only put in
three to five percent i am not super
interested in the people who either say
crypto is the solution to everything or
crypto is the devil i don't think either
is true and i think we've got to step
away from these like overly emotional
assessments of it
yeah i agree with you and i'm in the
same boat with crypto i just have i'm
not sure if it's like three percent
right now but like i'm kind of like
starting out with investing so i'm
probably gonna hold off on
buying crypto for now and just like
focus on just etfs but um yeah thank you
very much for taking my call and i hope
that i'll have time next time to call
you again i hope so all right oh from
dallas always great to hear from him
and kicking us off with some very very
strong topics
one of our sponsors is established
titles if you're looking for a perfect
last minute valentine's day gift check
this out it's funny it's unique and
they're supporting a great cause
established titles is a project based on
the historic scottish custom where
landowners are called lords and ladies
and so established titles lets you
ceremonially buy as little as one square
foot of dedicated land in aberdeenshire
scotland
so that you can call yourself a lord or
lady you get an official certificate
with a crest they let you see exactly
where your spot is located but in return
for each one sold established titles
will plant a tree to protect the
beautiful pristine woodlands of scotland
established titles also supports global
charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future so it's a fun gift
but you're also helping to support
something great and right now they're
having a huge valentine's day sale on
top of that you'll get an extra 10
percent off when you go to establish
titles.com pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below